hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 basics video in this video
we're going to be discussing some of the
basics to debugging in my videos i get a
lot of questions for help where people
have errors and they're not really sure
where the problem is but if they use
some basic and simple debugging they'd
realize how obvious the answer really is
so most of the time the problem is a
typo followed very closely to a
misunderstanding of indentation and
standards but usually it's a typo
and i guess they just don't understand
what the error is saying but every time
you see this error it's like you should
just automatically be like oh i must
have typo somewhere
so if you don't know what standards are
standards are basically how we organize
our code so with python unlike most
languages you define blocks of code
like functions with indentations so
define a function
and here is your functions code
everything goes in here and then
whenever the function is done it's just
literally
you just unindent and you start new
stuff so this is the function block and
this is not the function block and when
people start getting into trouble they
do stuff like this
and that gives them
problems with syntax
now there's obviously a lot of income
in in-depth common issues that you might
find from time to time and you can find
some more debugging videos
uh by searching for debugging in my
channel
for now i'm just going to keep these
examples pretty basic
the first error that we're going to
discuss is name error is not defined
so
an example of this one is going to be
variable equals 55
print
variable
so we've obviously type out variable and
we go to run and we get you know
name error variables not defined and
this sometimes drives people crazy
especially if maybe this is variable and
this is the typoed variable
and they say they see name arrow
variables not defined but they know they
just defined it like they just defined
it so they start freaking out but
almost always this is the case it's
they've just simply typoed
variable
now we can talk about indentation issues
here's an example of something i've seen
a few times
a task and then they come down here
task two
and then they start typing
whatever
and you get expected and indented block
and this just means that it expected
some sort of indentation here
another time
you'll see something similar
when it's expecting another indentation
yet slightly different is say you've got
print
or better yet a variable where it says x
equals
um
actually first we'll show print
print
and people maybe print
hello there then they come down here
and
immediately you should recognize that oh
something is wrong because python has
indented me and i don't know why and
it's for the reason before where you
could put something like this and then
more stuff
but then some people continue on
and you'll have print
f let's say and you run and it's just as
invalid syntax well that's not very
helpful to some people
especially if it's not going to
highlight where your invalid syntax is
but again generally it's because you
didn't close something off
now another common one that people are
going to get
is going to be the following it's going
to be eol while scanning string literal
this happens a lot if say you've got a
variable
and the variable is a string of text
and
like this string
and then
print
x
and we'll run you get eol while scanning
string literal and the reason why you
get this is the string never finished
yet we started a new line and he's very
frustrated so you'd have to close this
off
now those are just some of the common
things
i realized maybe that was just really
painfully slow for some of you guys
but this actually catches a lot of
people i'd say at least 90 percent
of the
um
problems that people have they you know
if they leave a comment and they're
having a debugging problem they've got
something wrong with their script they
can't figure it out
honestly ninety percent of the time uh
it's one of these things and of that
ninety percent probably ninety percent
of the time it's just a simple typo
so anyway i thought it'd be a good idea
to go ahead and cover that uh as far as
you know name or you know variable not
defined uh almost always a typo um so
sometimes people just don't understand
what the error is even saying to them so
they don't even know what to think so
anyway that's going to conclude this
video hopefully that was helpful for
some of you guys as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time